no ballot counting continues here in
nevada tonight even as key races have
been called
president-elect joe biden is projected
to win the state of nevada but the trump
team is fighting back here as well
orco manon joins us live outside the
clark county elections office in north
las vegas tonight
with more on what they and election
officials are saying
orco well sasha election workers here
are hard at work getting through the
thousands of ballots that still need to
be counted
as that continues the trump campaign and
the nevada gop
are once again alleging voter fraud in
nevada and specifically
in clark county
a crowd of trump supporters holding a
stop to steel protest in response to the
results of the 2020 election
the trump campaign and the nevada gop
joining them and continuing to allege
voter fraud in nevada
that this system that moved to mail-in
balloting
simply did not have enough checks in it
we pointed out that the
voter rolls in clark county had a lot of
improper
voters the trump team claiming they have
proof of thousands of examples of voter
irregularities this includes the
allegation
that at least two dead people in clark
county cast votes
i reached out to the county for a
statement and they tell me the claims
are being investigated
it appears one man's ballot was signed
by his daughter who did not cast her
ballot in this election
in the other case the woman's signature
is an identical match to what's in their
records
i'm sure that we have a good explanation
for anything that they put forth clark
county registrar of voters joe gloria
telling us sunday morning that 23
thousand mail ballots were put into the
system saturday
and a little over 16 thousand mail
ballots were left to be processed sunday
there are also 60 000 provisional
ballots that are being worked through
clark county will send information on
its provisionals to the nevada secretary
of state's office on monday
to make sure votes haven't already been
cast in other counties once they have
all 17
counties they'll begin to work so we're
hoping that by wednesday
we'll be prepared to start the automated
process of putting those ballots in that
should be counted into the system gloria
adds more than 25 mail-in ballots were
rejected on saturday because they were
not postmarked by the november third
deadline
there are currently less than two
thousand ballots that need to be cured
the deadline for that
is thursday november 12th
the nevada secretary of state's office
has consistently said
that there is no evidence of widespread
voter fraud in nevada
when i reached out to them to ask about
the allegations made today they tell me
they have no comment
at this time meanwhile the trump
campaign tells me that they are
currently looking
into legal options reporting live in
north las vegas tonight orca mana 8 news
now